this is Bobby Axelrod a likeable
character he um I think his self belief
is confidence I think is appealing I
think his blue-collar roots and the way
in which it Pitta mises the rise of the
working man and I suppose subscribed in
some way to the idea of the American
Dream that any man can make something of
himself and I think that's attractive to
people and I think it's appealing that
he is married to a woman of his own
background Marlon Ackerman who plays my
wife is staggeringly beautiful but she
is not a trophy wife is she someone that
he has known most of his life and is
from from the same sort of neighborhood
do you think he'd vote for Trump
he might
with The Sopranos kicking the whole
thing off sort of same time I was making
Band of Brothers TV just sort of changed
it became it became more global it
became less parochial less provincial
and I started to follow a film model
film directors and writers started
coming in then they would go and film in
Australia in the UK and all over the
world what they've done very well and
what they've been able to do because you
can tell a story over 12 hours rather
than just over two hours is you can have
these more complex arguably more complex
ambiguous characters and heroes who are
flawed and and anti-heroes who you you
want to like so I think both Bobby and
Chuck who is pooja Marty's character
occupy that territory
Metallica's showed up in the first
season we had a great time I got to
Quebec City and and actually it's a
little spoiler for people haven't seen
it that filmed a scene with Metallica
which was just fantastic and I'd met
Lars Ulrich a couple of times previously
but and he was kind enough to give a
pair of his drumsticks to mine to my son
who is a was a drummer so that's pretty
cool I think you'll see that thing which
drives both these men that in a tour of
ambition competition the need to succeed
the need to retain one's power this is
after all really a story about Kings in
their Kingdom it's very exciting to be
working and I feel very lucky I just
came of age as an actor at a time as as
the sort of as there was this sort of
tectonic shift between film and TV and
that's great fun
you